ladies and gentlemen that is a wrap on
season 3 of umbrella academy
more stunts more characters more action
that's what umbrella academy season 3 is
all about which actor got shredded for
this season how about who did all of
their own stunts we've got all the
behind the scenes secrets and more
coming your way i'm stoked because i
can't wait for you to see it number one
nothing quite beats the magic of a
filming studio while the umbrella
academy season 3 did film on location
for certain scenes plenty of time was
spent in the studio especially when it
came to those stunts and fight scenes
which let's face it was a major portion
for the third season number two
it definitely wasn't all fun and games
it was a lot of really long days of kind
of living in this high high emotional
state season three of umbrella academy
doesn't hold back any action and their
onset drills and rehearsals well they
speak for themselves talk about fears
there's a fight you know that um
i get to do
and
i'm really excited for people to see it
number three
this is ben like we've never seen him
before
even the actors were thrown i would
probably say
the new ben part of what helped us
witness how ben changed was his very
apparent and impressive physical
transformation they had all of us on
quite intense training regimens before
we started the show justin h min's
workout routine was intense but it
wasn't one he was opposed to at all it
was sort of nice to get into the
character in a physical way number four
can you say stunts
this crew definitely can after amping up
their superhero show to the next level
no matter the age if the actors wanted
to rough and tumble with the crew they
got to just ask javon walton who brought
his boxing skills to the set i do all my
own stunts so i get to showcase
sometimes my boxing ability and we
thought his stint on euphoria was
intense definitely take some discipline
take some hard work number five cue the
fit ape man we slimmed him down we got
him on the chicken and broccoli diet tom
hopper is in great shape but he's no
gorilla so he spent even more time with
his gorilla suit in season three but
this version was upgraded it has it has
evolved it's slimmer while it was a
smaller suit it was in no way made more
comfortable the thing is in the toronto
heat
um in the summer it gets there's no
escaping that no cooling suit underneath
no breaks just pure stamina is what got
tom hopper through
number six
say hello to the sparrows it almost felt
like working on a new show i was playing
a sort of a new character with a new
cast while the umbrellas and the
sparrows aren't really fans of each
other on screen off-screen they are
tight-knit as can be i just felt like it
really worked immediately the newcomers
came in and shook up the world of the
umbrellas especially the character who
seemed to be the most familiar to them
ben actor justin h min had an intense go
really exhausting to be in that
headspace for eight months which is how
long it took to shoot season three min
was playing a character he'd played for
a long time but there were some key
differences for this season he shared
that i got to work with a voice coach
while i was filming to slightly lower my
register as well as learn how to project
more and his spicy portrayal of ben on
screen shows all his hard work paid off
number seven
it wasn't used for what you might think
though his wise and calm demeanor make
us forget about the fact that aiden
gallagher was just 14 years old when he
started filming the first season of
umbrella academy since the filming for
season 3 took place when he was 17 there
were certain precautions and rules the
production team still had to follow this
included using a body double for any
scene that involved any kind of firearm
gallagher couldn't even be in the
building if any kind of explosion was
happening cue the body double and we can
bet this happened a whole lot
considering how wild some of the scenes
number five has been in are
number eight teamwork makes the dream
work throughout shooting the writers and
directors on set would discuss story
arcs with the actors ensuring everyone
was on the same page with the story they
were telling it was really important to
both of us that
that we would be doing her emmy raver
lantman dealt with some pretty heavy
emotions dealing with the aftermath of
what her character went through in the
season prior during the jim crow era a
lot of times depending on how emotional
this scene was i i couldn't but despite
the tough content she's still dug the
process it was so incredible i honestly
had the best time this season just kind
of being able to to be a little unhinged
and be unpredictable number nine a
trailer is a perfect place for a dance
party and from what we've gathered most
of the cast members took part in this
practice if grooving between takes like
this gets us the performances we see in
the third season then we are all for the
dancing vibes plus who doesn't love a
good dance montage
number 10 ain't no party like a
quarantine party
it was just super fun having your
friends around to play with the
production team filmed during the
pandemic so they kept it locked down on
set making for an extra safe and totally
coveted free set plus when they weren't
filming there wasn't much to do since
most of the world was in lockdown as
well but that didn't mean this cast
didn't have fun they only became closer
from all their hangouts offset to
singing and dancing along to the spice
girls before scenes
collaborative chill vibes on set that
produce action-packed entertainment the
umbrella academy team is on to something
and we're here for it which new
character is your favorite in season
three